no I think the written word is perfectly
sufficient you know it worked for Kafka
and if it doesn't work for me it's only
because I'm not good enough with the
written word I included images in
extremely loud and incredibly close
because I thought that they were
appropriate for that book I wanted to
capture the exuberance of this young boy
sort of his maximal imagination also his
imaginations desire or need to grasp at
lots and lots of things September 11th
was was the most visual event probably
in human history it was witnessed by
more people than anything else ever was
or husband and I thought that there was
a visual component to the to that event
that couldn't be separated from it and
when we think about September lemon we
think about the two towers that the
sight of them we think about the plane
going into them the sight of that so I
thought images were appropriate for that
book I don't think that they are
necessary or appropriate for every book
or most books
of course it will change and anybody who
thinks it won't is is not thinking it
through enough you know the New York
Times is now on the iPad right if the
New York Times didn't have video
embedded in it if you couldn't link from
one article to another if he couldn't
search back issues of the times if they
had a piece about this unbelievable shot
that you know rafael nadal hit and they
didn't have a clip of it we would say
that it was being negligent you know not
only that it wasn't taking advantage of
the vehicle but that it wasn't providing
us with the news that it could and
should and so there's going to be a real
pressure on novels when they start to be
right on screens which seems like an
inevitability to interact with the
vehicle I don't know what that will mean
I certainly don't know that that's a
good thing at all there are a lot of
reasons to think it's it's a bad thing
but it seems like an inevitability and
literature has always been slow slower
than the other art forms to grapple with
technological changes cultural changes
even you know when you look at a book
like freedom jonathan franzen's most
recent book there are many many ways in
which it could resemble the Odyssey you
know or Shakespeare and I think that's
one of the things that people love so
much about it and should love so much
about it but if you look at artists who
are now contemporary artists who are the
sort of peak of their game or the
forefront of their forms what they have
in common with artists working a hundred
years ago much less a couple thousand
years ago is almost nothing you know
music has changed so much in the last
fifty years and the visual arts are
barely even recognizable as art anymore
so maybe it's been the saving grace of
literature to be so conservative but
maybe it it will contribute to its death
I don't know